[Music]
Palestinians had declared the Trump deal
dead on arrival many months ago and as
he was preparing to unveil it in
Washington in the West Bank they were on
the streets in the White House the
coreography said it all to leaders keen
to find distractions keen to be
reelected unveiling the so-called deal
of the century
my vision presents a win-win opportunity
for both sides a realistic two-state
solution that resolves the risk of
Palestinian statehood to Israel's
security today Israel has taken a giant
step toward peace under this vision
Jerusalem will remain Israel's undivided
very important undivided capital there
were some seemingly warm words from the
president to the Palestinians but listen
to the cheers from the pro-israel
pro-trump crowd this was a gift for
Israel a non-starter for the
Palestinians and a delighted Israeli
prime minister spelt it out and this day
you too have charted a brilliant future
a brilliant future for Israelis
Palestinians and the region by
presenting a realistic path to a durable
peace after a meeting with his cabinet
the Palestinian President was live
addressing his people Jerusalem is not
for sale he said and your conspiracy
deal will not pass the Palestinian
people will reject it the status of this
place the Old City of Jerusalem goes to
the heart of the problems with this plan
the Trump proposal would make all of
this
East and West Jerusalem the capital of
the Jewish state of Israel the al-aqsa
mosque would be formerly Israeli
territory because for Israel it's on the
site of the first Jewish temples the
Palestinians mr. Trump said would get
their own capital in eastern Jerusalem
but it would be over there beyond the
Israeli separation wall
driving east out of Jerusalem you
reached the Jordan Valley in the West
Bank Palestinian land that will now be
annexed by Israel immediately the Jewish
settlements here too will become Israeli
sovereign territory despite the fact
that under international law they are
here illegally it will all cause huge
tension Israel is deploying more troops
to the area in preparation Vera baboon
is a member of the Palestinian National
Council and former mayor of Bethlehem
Donna Trump the Israeli leadership are
targeting to control annex or to have
sovereignty of these areas in
settlements but this is the question the
peace deal will it end in what in a
state to have a state we need that land
on the edge of Ramallah young
Palestinians clashed as usual with
Israeli soldiers it is their future
that's being molded we want to fight the
Israelis until freedom and victory they
tell us we will see much more of this in
the weeks ahead and well beyond